hello people my name is Greg my name is
John welcome to the real rejects hey
John what have you ever had to take a
big it see what I did there teaser
trailer number two TNT and before anyone
asks yes this is black nail polish and
my eyes are darker cuz I forgot to wash
off the eyeliner from yesterday when we
went to bar sinister oh boy we got
recognized by the most enthusiastic buff
dude we've ever met it had this guy
flipped out started kissing me he was
awesome they met Michael yeah it's one
of those you know if you're watching you
know I'm talking about you owe me I
remember you I know you if I saw you
were sure the chin strap was like yeah
no shirt very very rocket kept hugging
me hugging me a lot and then kissing me
and his friends were telling him to calm
down and I was like no let him yeah I
don't think I've ever had anybody just
be that my existence and so that was
that was just fun for me he said that we
were the inspiration for him is to start
pursuing film in college and now I feel
way ahead really anyway it's an all the
promotion we've done proposing yeah
[Music]
detective cared for me like he makes you
thanks should think it's too much hang
out with us makes you lose your - but
when you're alone as a kid
the machine is weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer till it's too late
whoa okay well I'm sorry
Ichi I'm pretty sure this is not the
same bathroom where's your mother
sometimes yeah any problem we got crabs
just shown that funny aren't you guys
coming in aa square water what the hell
is great one
it's basically piss and [ __ ] so I'm just
telling you
yeah just splash around in millions of
gallons of dairy paint so what are you
sure it's right don't smell like
automation you know so i'm sanitary your
little innocent blue are coming inside
of a toilet bowl right now mr. speaker
is it it's very urgent
if she's still here
[Music]
I don't know if this is gonna mess a
restricted mode John give me your hand
oh boy oh yeah oh yeah Wow Wow yeah well
at first I didn't think about what it
felt like but that is a that is an erect
nip yes yeah that is PG content right
there yeah for when the kid says the SH
word in here yeah and then the P I word
that says crabs but he couldn't be
referring to food restricting them out I
really love that will from stranger
things as cast in this yeah not the
slightest make distracting you have
administrators things yet no so let's
just right yeah still distract me
because I said there and after a couple
shots I was like wait a minute that's
the strange things stranger things of
the clown all right let's do it
yeah just right it's cool yeah if it
works one of the inspirations for
stranger things with Stephen King's
works though totally
oh yeah it's it's a weird typecasting
ruling he's good at it yeah I hope he
likes to do that but after this and
stranger things is done got a breakout
yeah I got a breakout man man sitcom
romantic comedies and that was a cool
trailer yeah I like how whoa they gave
us just a scene of dialogue between the
kids I mean I'm sure it was cut up a
little bit quicker to make it all move
faster for a trailer purpose I still
really enjoy that scene because you know
like I know stranger things was inspired
by things like it yeah but I think with
like stranger things being out and stuff
and then seeing this scene it works in
terms of promotional purposes because it
does get you invested in these kids like
these are lovable kids these are fun
children to hang out with well yeah I
think oddly enough just just paying
attention to what they've done so far
with this I think bless you and
obviously a spherical sump down there
Jon religious content please restricting
I actually think they're being pretty
smart about the marketing on this this
trailer seemed to have its mind in all
the right places it's like let's
establish the ensemble of kids because
to my understanding the first movie the
first half of this story is all
childhoods that's really important that
just give us a scene where everyone's
bantering back and forth and you're
seeing what the dynamic of the movie is
gonna be like I thought that was a great
choice and the way they're teasing
Pennywise like showing like we finally
see his whole face in a good shot now
yeah you know and that darn sound they
keep it yeah is so jarring and creepy
and even the horror movie imagery like
when he's walking up to the house and
the angles get all creepy like the
balloon effects are great too yeah
balloons have never looked more
terrifying he's gonna play it's gonna be
the shipping off to the bastion of this
movie that's the actual song in when the
balloons start releasing yeah it has a
humor within the characters but the
horror looks effective it seems like
this could be a very effective foreign
movie it looks like are they still doing
two parts to my understanding yoga
because the second movies oh and they're
adults cuz I know there's a problem they
have when trying to get a greenlit I
think oddly enough that might be like
this might be the the happy byproduct of
them splitting up all these like final
installments of a series into two
because maybe now we can do it this way
where it's like oh this story just
needed to be two movies well what I'm
hoping is here's here's my hope you
complete this movie part this part one
but you end it in a way worth that it
could feel like this is the end to the
story I don't want it to end in a way
where you're like we got to get part two
we got to have the cliff you know we
need to stall a clipping or for a part
two I think what they should do is end
it and be and this is where I get
serious is the last part was just a joke
they should wait twenty years and he's
the same act
now cool with that like boyhood like
boys yeah boyhood with it I like that
just make it 20 years the same actors
I'm telling you people will tune and
it'll be the most anticipated sequel for
the next couple decades yeah I ever want
something everyone's gonna come back and
then you cross it over with strangers
and daddies both characters yeah you
love him he can fight himself and they
look so different one has glasses
the other doesn't this way we can
distinguish between the two it all right
well that was a cool teaser trailer hey
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects go check
out our patreon where we have exclusive
content on there including deleted
scenes movie news segments that we got a
shoot and Johnny's reasons to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum House keep a look over
we only got like five you know there are
ten more announcements to make
keep a lookout for our mo damn blah blah
blah now Snowdown double toasty vs. real
reject double toast to click that
notification break we are almost done
when the merch say the notification bell
again cuz I said the F word we can't do
that click that notification bell John
yes you must adjust quicker I'm sorry
and hurried away we're gonna love double
dose